what sorcery is this
you can't poor sound is this truth or
troll an actual fact it's both and
here's why when she holds the pipe over
the flame to heat it up she's actually
heating up a very specific part there's
a metal mesh inside the pipe that we
can't see when that mesh gets hot enough
it heats up the air near it and causes
that air to rise as the air rises
through the pipe it has to work its way
through the holes in the mesh and as it
does this it becomes turbulence creating
vibrations that resonate inside the pipe
which she hears as the pipe singing this
effect only works when the pipe is
vertical if the pipe is horizontal the
mesh does still hit the air that the air
doesn't go through the mesh as it rises
up and out of the pipe pretending to
pour something into the cup is just an
excuse to hold the pipe horizontally and
make the sound stop for the grand finale
you syrup puts the pipe upright the
turbulent air is allowed to continue its
path up the tube making that beautiful
noise yes pouring Sun will always be a
pipe dream they accepted in Simon's case
so if you bring it up I can get the
pitch right
you